Joe Biden says that personally he's not
big on abortion but he supports Roe v
Wade there are some on the left
criticizing Biden for this I have to
tell you guys I don't get it I don't
think this is it to me it is a great
thing to hear from an elected official I
have a view I don't love abortion but
I'm not going out trying to make it
illegal I'm not trying to shame those
who do choose that that is the right
thing for them in consultation with
their doctors this is called separation
of church and state so I understand if
Joe Biden were shaming people or saying
because I'm personally not big on
abortion I'm going to try to ban it or
whatever this is the whole point you get
to have whatever view when we say we are
pro-choice guys we're I'm pro-choice
okay so that means I want people to be
able to choose whatever is best for them
they might choose that abortion is
what's best for them or they might not